so this diagram over here I have this
big triangle and then I have all these
other little triangles inside of this
big triangle and what I want to do is
see if I can figure out the measure of
this angle right here and we'll call
that measure theta and they tell us a
few other things the use you might have
seen this symbol before that means that
these are right angles or that they have
a measure of 90 degrees so that's a 90
degree angle that is a 90 degree angle
and that is a 90 degree angle over there
they also tell us that this angle over
here is 32 degrees so let's see what we
can do and maybe we can solve this in
multiple different ways that's what's
really fun about these is there's
multiple ways to solve these problems so
if this angle is Theta we have theta is
adjacent to this angle is adjacent to
this green angle and if you add them
together you're going to get this right
angle you're going to get this right
angle so this this this pink angle theta
plus this green angle must be equal to
90 degrees they when you combine them
you get a right angle so you could call
this one this measure is going to be 90
minus theta and now we have now we have
three angles in the Triangle and we just
have to solve for theta because we know
this angle Plus this angle Plus this
angle are going to be equal to 180
degrees so you have 90 minus theta plus
90 degrees so plus 90 degrees plus 90
degrees plus 32 degrees so let me do
that in a different color plus 32
degrees plus 32 degrees is going to be
equal to 180 degrees the sum of the
measures of the angle inside of a
triangle add up to 180 degrees that's
all we're doing over here and so let's
see if we can simplify this a little bit
so if we subtract so these two guys 90
plus 90 is going to be 180 so you get
180 minus theta plus 32 is equal to 180
degrees and then we have what else do we
have we have 180 on both sides we can
subtract that from both sides so that
cancels out that goes to zero and you
have negative theta plus 32 degrees is
equal to zero you can add theta to both
sides and you get 32 degrees is equal to
theta or theta is equal to
thirty-two degrees so it's going to
actually be the same it's going to be
the same measure as this angle right
over here that's one way to do the
problem there's other ways that we could
have done the problem we could have said
and actually there's a ton of ways we
can done this we could have looked at
this big triangle over here we can say
look if this is 90 degrees over here
this is 32 degrees over here this angle
up here is going to be 180 minus 90
degrees minus 32 degrees because they
all have to add up to 180 degrees and I
just kind of skipped a step there
obviously this let me actually not skip
a step let me call this X if we call
that the measure of that angle X we
would have X plus 90 I'm looking at this
the biggest triangle in this diagram
right here X plus 90 plus 32 plus 32 is
going to be equal to 180 degrees and so
you if you subtract 90 and 32 from both
sides so if you subtract 90 from both
sides you get X plus 32 is equal to 90
and then if you subtract 32 from both
sides you get X is equal to what is this
58 degrees X is equal to 58 degrees X is
equal to 58 degrees fair enough now what
else can we figure out well if this
angle over here if this angle over here
is a right angle and I'm just redoing
the problem over again just to show you
that there's multiple ways to get the
answer we were given that this is a
right angle if that is 90 degrees then
this angle over here is supplementary to
it and it also has to be it also has to
be 90 degrees so then we have this angle
plus 90 degrees Plus this angle Plus
this angle have to equal 180 maybe we
could call that Y so Y plus 58 plus 90
is equal to 180 you can subtract 90 from
both sides subtract 90 from both sides
this will become 90 subtract 58 from
both sides you get Y is equal to 32
degrees Y is equal to 32 degrees well if
Y is 32 degrees it is it is
complementary it adds up it is
complementary to this angle right over
here it is complementary let me do that
in a new color
not supplementary dis complimentary it
adds up to 90 degrees it is
complementary to this angle over here we
could call it Z so these two combined
are going to add up to 90 degrees or Z
is going to be equal to 58 degrees and
now we're inside the triangle that we
care about to figure out theta theta
that we've already figured out earlier
in this video
well this Z is 58 degrees if this angle
over here is 90 then this one over here
is also going to be 90 because they're
supplementary so you have 58 degrees you
have 58 degrees I wanted to do that in
that orange color so if you have 58
degrees so you have 58 Plus this 90 plus
90 Plus theta now Plus theta now is
going to be equal to 180 degrees you can
subtract 90 from both sides that becomes
90 and then you have 58 plus theta is
equal to 90 subtract 58 from both sides
you get theta is equal to 32 degrees
again and so we get the same answer I
just wanted to do that show you that
there are multiple ways to do these
problems and as long as you're doing
things that are logically consistent
you're making you're making assumptions
that you can make and then logically
deducing step by step there's multiple
ways to get that right answer